I know God's making a big comeback in  this country I feel it I talk to people  who say I started to return to church I  brought God back into our family's lives  it's so important right now we're due  for a couple of Miracles I think it's  just such a fantasy world that these  people live in but I also believe we  have on top of of that we have a really  good court case and we're going to open  people's eyes to what went wrong you  know there's times I felt just like the  voters out there in Arizona  despondent over the last couple of weeks  right because we had such a we have such  an amazing movement and then I think  about what God you know our father is  doing he's imagine if you if your dad  said to you I have such great hope for  you and I I believe in you so much that  I'm going to put you in charge of  something difficult oh this is just so  crazy listen if God wanted her to win  why didn't she just win